when I first went to Gombe it was the
most amazing time of my life
[Music]
imagine how I felt the first time powers
of Dwight final victim's wife is on
three felony one of the things which is
important for her is to get away and
retouch her roots
[Music]
okay everything which is happening today
is because of the experiences she had in
the first and she needs to take strength
from that the alone in the forest is
what matters chair
[Music]
[Music]
out in the forest I had this very strong
feeling of great spiritual power out
there it was the kind of feeling that I
sometimes have in one of the old
cathedrals where people have been to
worship yeah after year after year the
chimpanzees I knew in the old days are
almost all gone but one of the ones who
was quite real I say friend was gremlin
the last time I actually saw a gremlin
she came right up to me and looked into
my eyes I mean of course they recognized
us just as we recognized them
[Music]
I've always had a strange connection
with animals I connect with people with
words with animals it's more
mind-to-mind so many things in my life
seem to be coincidence but I'm not sure
I believe that a bit more because things
happen
I think they seem to happen for a reason
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]